don't overthink it just relax let him
see the man underneath
[Applause]
you know I've been asking myself what
possible wisdom I can impart to the
bright young minds of tomorrow be anyone
you want to be if you get what you
believe in it makes you righteous angry
I believe in you Sam get to the core of
who you really are
you just cultivate that clean image
Nigel my mother taught me from an early
age to fight for justice protect those
who are vulnerable this is what we're
selling confidence hope optimism to your
mythology is your best asset be honest
about your weaknesses but capitalize on
your strengths because really you can
only be you be you whoever that is thank
you he's very very good at what it does
fooling everyone the right man for the
job then everyone's got a dark side
I'm only get to see there's two of you I
wanna speak to you whatever Messer and
you did yourself out of it help people
are gonna know what you need
I'd be careful here sounds like you're
fishing there at this story this is
about you protecting your ticket to the
top exam about your zipper drum people
want to believe if you're somehow better
than they are
this is a black and white issue they
need that fairy tale I set out to help
people I never said I was better than
them everybody's just waiting for you to
win this Sam yeah whatever you need this
is the perfect time to get used to
surprises
[Music]
what did you do remember all the goals
we set for ourselves does not throw that
away
people still mean heroes let's give them
one
[Music]
you